bonjour brut c'est fred avec ce show je
sais que ma communauté en fait véhicule
beaucoup de préjugés et de clichés et
ben moi je vais vous montrer en fait ce
qui est réellement la communauté
asiatique dans le chinatown le paris
xiii parisien et donc c'est parti salut
ça va
véronique est quelqu'un qui est que
j'affectionne énormément
ces couacs un incontournable dans xiiie
arrondissement par exemple ce serait
quoi la différence entre le le cambodge
le laos le vietnam la chine la corée et
j'en passe et des meilleurs parce que
pour beaucoup de gens en fait dans
l'inconscient des gens tous ces pays que
je viens de citer
c'est la chine oui mais pour les gens
les gens de tous ces gens là c'est des
chinois tu vas après c'est une question
qui est difficile parce que si on
prenait l'exemple de la communauté
afrique noire comment on fait de la
différenciation entre un sénégalais un
togolais un malien
mais ne serait-ce que physique c'est
vrai que c'est moi j'essaie de me mettre
à leur place et je me dire c'est une
difficulté quand même mais à côté de ça
ce serait avoir une curiosité en fait de
se dire là c'est quoi tes origines au
lieu de tout de suite balancer tiens tu
es chinois voilà
dire c'est quoi des origines parce que
ça te dépasser mais messi oui mais si la
famille si elle veut pas alex prime un
des regards mais donnez nous la liberté
en fait de deux d'être pleinement
identifiés
ce temple là en fait j'y allais depuis
que je suis tout petit mes parents
m'emmenaient en fête le dimanche faire
les courses et tout de suite après on
allait manger dans un restaurant dans le
xiiie et après on aller se recueillir en
je suis juste venu montrer en fait le
temple où je viens depuis que suis tout
petit et voilà bon on va pas vous
déranger plus longtemps à bientôt
au revoir elle est très mal à l'aise la
dame et qui on parlait parce que déjà dû
ni à des caméras
c'est surtout parce qu'il ya des caméras
parce que je la connais depuis tout
petit et mais vous le dira jamais parce
que elle a peur de gêner elle a peur de
deux vous froisser
j'ai souvent défini notre moyen de
communication dans la culture asiatique
comme un moyen de non communication
parce que parce que cette pudeur fait
qu'on se taire parfois dans le silence
et moi pour prendre l'exemple de mes
parents ils m'ont ils m'ont jamais dit
en fait leur histoire et j'ai découvert
que mes parents étaient survivants d'un
génocide à l'âge de 26 ans en regardant
un documentaire de rithy panh qui
s'appelle s-21 en fait et à partir de là
en fait j'ai une quête de vouloir
connaître mon histoire mon identité ma
culture donc j'ai refait un une sorte de
chemin inverse de cheminement inverse
vers père qui j'étais en fait
profondément
exactement
ouais on est dans le xiiie mais quand on
regarde les enfants c'est très mélangées
et finalement quand j'observe je vois
bout peu d'asiatiques
donc il ya une sorte de vrai melting-pot
en fait qu'à dans le 13e mois je suis
très content parce que à l'époque on ya
vécu et des asiatiques et là il ya un
vrai brassage
[Musique]
ce que je raconte dans le film c'est une
quête il vers son identité
c'est mon personnage françois qui qui a
fait un rejet de ses origines parce que
il a passé toute son enfance à subir des
moqueries lie à sa différence physique
et forcément il a fait ce rejet là sauf
que
quand sa femme lui annonce qu'il va être
papa eh bien
ben ça fait bouger beaucoup de choses en
lui et du coup il décide de revenir dans
xiiie arrondissement pour renouer
contact avec avec son père sa famille et
surtout ses origines et son identité et
ses racines
ouais mon histoire c'est ça c'est mon
histoire c'est que j'ai fait un rejet
j'ai fait un rejet mais sur les origines
parce que on n'arrêtait pas de me suivre
ligne et ma différence physique les 15
ans ont donné j'en ai j'en avais marre
et et j'ai fait ce rejet là parce que je
voulais plus blanc que blanc et du coup
quand j'ai fait quand je me suis posé
cette question là parce que j'étais je
vivais mal et un moment donné en fait
dans ma dans mon évolution j'ai compris
que tout ce qui m'est arrivé de bien
dans ma vie c'était grâce à mes origines
donc je me devais de me réconcilier avec
ça et de refaire de faire machine
arrière
aider dans cette quête là et du coup
aujourd'hui je suis je suis complètement
en paix avec qui fut parce que je suis
reparti en chine je partis au vietnam je
suis parti aux compotes j'ai passé du
temps avec mes parents mes grands
parents
on a crevé les abcès et et maintenant je
me sens pleinement rempli nomades dans
ma double culture